[Music]
donald glover opens up about his
history-making Emmys wins I always
wanted to just make good thing like
that's all that's important to me I'm a
33 year old actor took home an emmy for
outstanding directing for a comedy
series during the 69th Annual Primetime
Emmy Awards on Sunday making him the
fourth black nominee and first ever
winner in the category
he also took home the award for lead
actor in a comedy series becoming the
first african-american to do so since
1985 while accepting his Emmy Glover
announced he's expecting another child
I want to thank Michelle my partner you
love me even went out how crazy I get I
want to thank my baby my son for for
just being the joy in my life I want to
thank my unborn son we're listening to
Stevie tonight he's Kevin Frazier spoke
with Glover backstage about his big wins
and baby number two did you just
announce that you have another baby on
the way yeah you do yes congratulations
thank you so much how long told that
that child arrives I don't know like it
says like it feels like I'm even
pregnant for a long time but like
probably about entity here sometime I
think though you said some milestones
tonight you realize that right
you understand was just told that I
didn't realize that was what was
happening I didn't know that I'm glad I
didn't know that was gonna be a thing
how do you digest something like that
you take everything the way it's given
to you like you know I try I just you
know I always wanted to just make good
things like that's all that's important
to me I'm like quality is for the people
I try and we we always talk about in
Atlanta's writers room just make
something quality and hopefully people
so I never yeah I never thought about in
those terms I just want to make
something good you said you're done with
music is that true I mean I'm never done
with music but but I you know I I like
walking away from things just to let
things breathe like I don't I don't
necessarily I don't want to be forced to
make anything because I feel like once
you get forced to make something it
turns out really bad so I don't feel
like I have to make
I don't feel like I have to make music I
just don't want to make
[Music]
you